my name is stages that's pronounced like
contagious for those of you who have a
little bit of trouble with this exotic
Indian name and actually it does mean
Sun like a ray of sunshine I don't know
how you knew that but you know your MC
the emcees do background checks I'm
convinced which I signed a form or
something that's fine but today anyway
we're not here to talk about me we're
here to talk about rest how many of you
have heard of rest how many of you used
Rasim okay that's the whole room whoa
that's surprising we are here to talk
about rest and graph QL and stuff and in
our time together what I want to show
you is you know I thought long and hard
about it what I really want to show you
is that constraints can be really
beautiful things I think that's in a
nutshell what I want to show you and I
thought about the best way to do that
how can I communicate in a way that you
know will not have you like scrolling
through your phone or falling asleep I
saw some of you asleep in a previous
talk I want it I want to talk to you in
a way that engages you I think the best
way to do that is to tell you a story
the story starts where all great stories
start and that is with JavaScript okay
and you know this is we had a code base
at my previous employer it was a great
it was a really good product people
really wanted it people were paying for
it we had it was good it's it had helped
the company even make profit but what
ended up happening was over time the
code became stale it started to get a
little bit old which eventually led to
you know old code it led to stale code
and because it was JavaScript it just
kind of stuck around how many of you
know what I'm talking about like you're
sometimes afraid to delete your code
because oh my goodness I might break
something right you're afraid to rename
you're afraid to refactor and if you
build software we saw from max this
morning what make it work make it right
and make it fast but how can I make it
fast how can I be factored if I'm scared
to break stuff and that's where we found
ourselves we were feature frozen but
kind of without our choice
we just were really afraid to make
changes now how do we help this
thankfully there's there's technology
that and makes javascript scale a little
bit better and and makes us a little bit
more confident that we believe I believe
is typescript we decided okay we can't
build on this thing anymore this
monolith is a little bit hard to
maintain
so we'll recreate something and we'll
try and do it right we'll try and do it
with typescript okay and and what that
led us to didn't what lead I'm speaking
faster than I can think happens but what
that led to was our code ended up
scaling really well like all of a sudden
we saw so many benefits from from the
static type analysis that typescript
gives you that we could confidently
delete code we could confidently
refactor our documentation was on point
and you know some of you were skeptical
I'm looking around the room something
you're going like ah he's talking about
types here I'm leaving stay because I'll
show you practically some of the
benefits we got from typescript now I
think it becomes exceedingly clear in
the area of design systems how many of
you have a design system work with a
design system a lot of you and it's good
and if you have a design system what
it's a library meaning the API is
something that's important like if you
want people to import it and use it you
want to expose an API that is we say
it's idiomatic its approachable its
you're used to it our API documentation
is generated and expose using this tool
called react style guide is actually the
author of this is here somewhere go say
hi and tell him good job for me he's a
very talented person and you know I'll
just show you some ways that typescript
gives us benefits right now so we're
gonna exit out of this I'm going to
mirror my screen which I should have
done before but I was busy socializing
it's a conference all right there we go
okay so this is our design system it's
called operational UI and it looks very
simple but here's here's what we're
typescript really helps if we go to say
avatar okay these are some names this is
kind of like a Google Gmail type of
avatar
thing which generates a circle with
initials that's the Avatar component and
it's something we use across their app
you probably do this in your design
system as well what's it really
important to us is the API so I click
this view code thing and what I see is
an interactive code playground so I can
you know I can go in here I can see what
it looks like with different names and I
can see it update in real time right
vivek is a good friend of mine sitting
right here and so you can see it kind of
update in real time what what what I
want to show you is how the API
documentation can help and how we do
that through typescript is this way
typescript exposes type declaration
files that give you powerful features in
your IDE like Auto completion like type
analysis so if something's not
compatible you get red squiggly
underlines and you know it okay what we
have done in the documentation here
literally just for fun just a hobby
project was we took a vias code the
engine under it so Monaco is called a
Monaco editor and we kind of put it in
the browser and we we fed type
declarations into it and so if I go here
look what it says press alt space inside
a component for available props
documentation I'm gonna do that so I
press this and these are the props that
are available to me okay and in order to
fully appreciate this look I get like a
go color and I could say red man red
what else is available to me I can say I
want to hide the initials I don't really
know why ok very good
hides mean issues we just have a red
circle at this point and I could say I
want it to be huge but look I can't get
a 4000 pixel radius why and I have
intelligent documentation here it's
because oh I'm only expecting small or
medium and so surely enough I can go
here and say okay I want medium BAM it's
done so typescript is able to give us
auto completion and like next-level
documentation that we can't get any
other way and the cool thing is because
of style guide us all of this is just
generated from mock down like like we
don't we don't really do any work we
just write text files let me show you so
if I if I go here to github it's
open-source you're welcome to go look at
it Conte our most operational UI we go
to source and I can go to avatar
if the internet lets me there we go so
avatar thank you whoever just went off
the Wi-Fi and what we see is this
markdown is title and code snippet is
exactly the same one-to-one is this we
just it looks a little bit different but
the true fact is that this is generated
automatically from this ok we write text
it big it comes to life and then it
comes to new life with typescript very
exciting and because of that we've seen
our apps be bulletproof and I don't have
the time to go into the details of how
we were able to do this I did do a talk
in react Finland earlier this year with
more technical details it involves
simulating a file system in the browser
it's a lot of fun and I'd recommend
going to look at that but that's not why
we're here today we're here to talk
about rest graph QL and typescript so
we're in the middle of a story and in
this story we've adopted typescript and
we were seeing benefits yeah I mean
those those are benefits right
we took it further we turned all of this
trick new settings on everything was was
read and then we made it not read and we
have just amazing scale our apps were
effectively bulletproof honestly nothing
broke them we'd get no emails from
sentry except in one place and this is
not an email but this is an incoming
packet our apps would break the network
layer okay robin two-degree talked about
IOT s earlier where that's the that's
the dead that's the scary zone the i/o
layer and so we would receive things
from the backend that were unexpected
and what would happen cannot read
property something of undefined right
like it's the JavaScript nightmare back
again and so we would our back-end would
send us these mysterious things
sometimes and there's no disrespect to
the back-end team it just happens
sometimes people are offline which
eventually made our apps blow up which
made us very sad because there were bugs
and so we were like crying about it so
you like okay our apps are bulletproof
but if I see another network related
error I'm going to be very very sad
and that brings me to the point in the
story where I just want to tell you rest
is is many things but unfortunately rest
is just not that good okay and and this
is maybe a controversial opinion
especially cuz so many hands went up
when I asked but look we're engineers we
don't just say something's not good we
say it's not good because there's a
magical word in engineering
let's substantiate this claim a little
bit rest is just not good because well
for one thing it's not a formal
specification like show me a formal
specification for there isn't one you
know what that mean that means it leads
to a lot of guessing games oh this this
should definitely be a put not a patch
but why this is a like is it a post as
it put it so here's here's a question
right someone requests a resource on
your extremely secure blockchain
back-end and they're not allowed to see
it now do they get a 401 do they get a
403 do they get a 404 cuz they shouldn't
even know it exists what you're doing
right now is you're guessing because
this isn't documenting you and this is
this happens way too much how about this
one something doesn't exist what status
code it's always complicated and
ultimately my problem with this and I am
angry I'm just kidding act but the the
problem I have this is as engineering
teams we have a lot of meaningless
discussions should this be a put should
this be a patch I don't care I want my
users our users to benefit from our
amazing products I think we all want the
same thing
fundamentally the issue with rest is
this there are no contractual agreements
between front and back and you could you
could documents - sure there's there's
ways around it but fundamentally that's
where at I think I can best summarize
all of this with this message that
actually happened though the time is a
little bit off this happened at some
point there was a conversation and I had
to ask this way race also put create
something but I thought put was reddit
and my response to this is just ok but
like why
why can't we have a better way
thankfully there is something called
graphic you how many of you know graph
QL use graphic you love graphed more
heads than rest this is a very good
thing
graph key well I would say my friends
and I'm happy you agree is very good
okay and it's very good we look we're
engineers we don't just say this stuff
what's the magic word because it's very
good because basically the opposite of
the rest points it is a formal
specification if graph QL is one thing
it is not some type of paradigm for
client-server communication it's not a
proto cuts it is a spec it's just a
specification and for that for me this
is a huge huge deal you know what that
means that means there's no guessing
games that means you know you know you
send a post with a data and you get back
some delay it's it's it's specified and
if you find something that you you're
guessing about guess what you guess what
if you find something that makes you
guess you could open an issue you could
contribute a solution back to the spec
and then it becomes the specification
and you help a huge chunk of the world
that's incredible and for me the biggest
value is that it leads to really
meaningful discussions we're no longer
talking about what is this status code o
is what verb is that put patch post
delete update and there's an updates are
over
now we talked about can we cache this
can we can we can we reduce the size of
the pic and we do things that affect the
user in a positive way that's why we
build software and graph QL makes that
up and center front and center and
lastly graph QL gives us really strong
contractual agreement so you you
describe your schema you say hey these
are my things they live here and and you
establish this contract for your API and
for these reasons I think graph QL has a
lot of value but you know what this is
just this this is just the just the
developer experience stuff this is like
cross-team stuff if we were to talk
about the user experience benefits of
graph QL we would have to go like off
the screen like
right and and you laugh but is the truth
this is the truth so I think I've made
my point graph QL is very very good now
I was I was at a I was here in Berlin as
a conference actually with my coworker
from beyond here and we there was like a
talk about how to convince your boss to
adopt graph QL apart from showing them
this talk people this is a problem
people had they were like okay graph QL
is amazing but nobody sees the whole
picture how do we convince people and in
this talk there was this notion of this
conversation being had a lot somebody
says hey I want to add a graph QL
service to our stack mister CTO mr. Cee
or whatever and the response is well you
know we just read it we can't because
reasons reasons and and the top the top
reasons were really I don't get them
again here's that word because you want
to take a picture we can go back let's
see a person back too much it's okay you
can just interrupt my presentation
casually okay good okay so because they
say well we just don't trust JavaScript
for an API JavaScript i language you use
it you use it to make like blocks and
counter them to do MVC's come on use it
for api we we already have a api team
and they have tasks if you don't believe
me just go look in JIRA oh what's that
year it doesn't work oh sorry okay or
how about this one this is we just don't
have the time for that you know we hey
agile scrum its meetings committees you
know so we just need to ship we need to
ship we need to ship the problem is when
you laugh because you relate but when
you have this culture you ship things
that the user doesn't like you know you
ship things that cause runtime
exceptions you ship things that break at
the network layer and and I've
experienced this firsthand and so all
that to say my response to these reasons
is this but at some point you go okay
you know what let's make it work it's
fine but then your entire team goes okay
well and so what is the solution how can
we is there hope for us stuck in the
land of
I think so I think so so this is where
we find ourselves in the story okay you
have a constraint and the constraint
makes you sad you could either just kind
of wrestle with it you could fight you
do politics you can back by your gonna
whatever you want or you could say hey
it's time for a side project it's time
to innovate constraints can drive
innovation you can tweet that because
that needs repeating constraints can
drive innovation I was heavily inspired
by the Apollo project around graph QL
for those of you who know it I mean it's
incredible they have client/server and
it's just stunning and it's mostly
typescript in the api's and it's I could
talk all day about how amazing Apollo is
so that inspire the creation of a
similar library so I made a library on a
Saturday
we call it restful reactant it's not
some variant of renaming things as hard
it's just how you fetch data in a
predictable way more or less um with
react in rest and apart from like
talking about it like I'd show you I
show you some some demos of restful
react so let's go here I'll open up my
editor he's offended because I said the
rest is not good I'm just kidding
it's kidding so we have this this is my
app and it says hello react Dave Berlin
but this is kind of not really fun for
you so let's do something let's open a
browser let me just actually yarn start
this bad boy okay and I will open a
browser here and we'll do split screen
so okay and there so what we'll do is
you go localhost 8080 I believe it's
running there and it's I mean it's what
you'd expect it's a react app nothing
special just hello react a Berlin with a
lot of fire and metal signs how restful
react works is you wrap your entire app
in a provider provider from a restful
react and you just you need to kind of
give it some context to tell it like hey
I'm talking to this service okay so I'm
just gonna you've probably done this
with a lot of other things and now it's
read why because typescript saying no I
can't I need a base prop I need to know
who you're talking
it's base equals we will talk to my
favorite API in the whole world
okay this is the dog API absolutely love
it
dog does CEO and so we're gonna do our
app will not change at all because well
nothing changed except we added some
context so we'll go in here and we'll
use it a react took it's called use get
so I will import I don't even need
looked at sure will give me automatic
import Const addy structure something
and I'll use get okay BAM and I will say
I want stuff from the dog API I want
breeds image random I believe apologize
if this doesn't work but I just want a
really good dog on the screen and I get
data what else do I get I get a my
loading and I get an error okay okay and
so now if I'm loading I want to say a
huge like am loading if I have an error
I want to just log I guess the air dots
message and lastly if I have data I want
to IMG alt always use your alt good way
and we have data dot message I believe
but see notice this I'm guessing I don't
really know this message thing exists
and if I look at what data is it's just
anything so this let's see that works
okay it works great but the problem is
and this is kind of why your app was
breaking I could turn message into like
massage right and then of course it
doesn't work everything breaks oh no
it's on fire we can't ship so how I can
fix this is using generics and
typescript to kind of mock the shape of
my back-end response so I go here and
say I'm expecting something with data
sorry with message as a string okay and
now it's like okay fine
message no message three no whatever it
doesn't doesn't really exist it doesn't
exist it wants data dot message this is
fine this is already some a good a good
way forward and it's working and that's
pretty great so that's that's an initial
restful react and it works really nicely
right would you agree would you disagree
it doesn't matter I have the microphone
but can we do better let's revisit so we
said rest is just not good because and
we went through the reasons you won't do
that again we just look at them again
because I feel the pain of rest still
but that last point no contractual
agreements is kind of sort of malleable
is you can you kind of bend that a
little bit because there are some
contractual agreements you see our
back-end was implemented in golang I
can't say if it's a good language or I
was gonna say it's a great language just
my nature but I don't know
and so the API is you know strongly
typed the api's are documented and so my
amazing co-worker Fabio I took this
picture today's sitting right here give
it up for everybody he's up so um yeah
what he did was he wrote something to go
to the NGO source code and pull out
typescript definitions it's amazing the
great tool full of regular expressions
but it really works we were inspired by
this to go can we actually do this and
so we looked into open API now open API
is an evolution of swagger okay and it's
a way of describing your back-end
response or your back-end API entirely
your REST API post put patch get delete
and all the status codes and everything
in Yama or JSON and we were like okay
this gives us an idea whoa there's
something here problem is unlike your
graph QL schema definition these things
are big they're very big and so we
worked with them a bit for everyone read
them and usually okay this I'm reading
this once and probably never again
so can we somehow use this specifically
confirm yeah somehow use this so he had
the idea for cogent you know use like
okay we have information let's see if we
can generate some stuff and that is what
we have today this I need to preface
this allows for something really
innovative an advantage from graph QL
that we now have in rest my friends and
that is end to end type safety now I'd
love to show that to you now so we're
going to go back to our split screen and
we're gonna talk to a different API so
we're going to go here and instead
talking to dog CEO as much as I love it
we're gonna talk to API dot how do you
say it gif or Jif II giffy I heard gif
he first so we go with that API doc gif
EECOM slash everyone and of course this
is gonna break we're gonna see nothing
failed to fetch 404 expected and we're
gonna we're and do something so restful
react exposes a CLI okay as well so a
command-line interface there was a great
lightning talk on those but my friend
chatroom and how it works is this you
you say yarn restful reacts you access
the binary react and you import from you
could import it from a file and what it
expect is an open API or swagger
document okay you can import that from
your filesystem from your hard drive
from wherever or if you want to be fancy
you can go okay I this lives on github
so you can literally just like it will
go to github fetch the document and come
back and you fill out some your github
username the repo name the branch name
and the file path and you tell it hey I
want to output this here on my file
system okay and I will hit enter and
it's gonna go off and get that stuff and
done so it executed in one point five
three seconds and if I look here I look
it's a green file I have a new file you
want to look inside let's let's look so
it's a whole bunch of types and we you
know we don't really need to concern
ourselves with these because it exists
we can use them okay shall we try let's
try using it let's fetch some data from
Givi jiffy iffy what and see if it works
now we did loading error and data so we
don't really need to change that because
it's the same restful react as the same
API so I'm going to remove this import
from restful react and this is going to
yell at me yes I know use get doesn't
exist but it's we're gonna instead
import something from our API so I'll
import something from dot slash API now
restful react takes API documentation
gives you react hooks we need to find
something in this huge ocean of stuff
how do we find hooks use so we type use
look these are the things that are
available from giffy we just access them
so let's try and get a random gift mmm
no more use get but use random gift we
don't need this generic type anymore
it's fully typesafe it knows it doesn't
expect a path it actually just expects
an MD object and look at this end and
type say if it's like message doesn't
exist
that's incredible okay instead what do I
have I have data dot okay well I guess
data again maybe I should rename data to
like gif response just so I don't
confuse myself okay but it's not a
string it doesn't go in the image so I
need something else dot image is and
look I have this auto-completion right
here I haven't left the editor dot
original I believe dot and then lastly
the URL which is a string and now my SRC
is satisfied I have some optional
chaining going on which is stage-four by
the way in JavaScript yeah that's right
and save and what I should see is a
error 401 because I am not authenticated
now I need an API token and giffy does
this via query parameter Y I think it's
not really safe but okay pretend you
don't see my token I will revoke it
after the talk I'm just gonna copy this
token cowboy-style and we'll say a query
params API key is my API key again I
will revoke it so if you want to abuse
me just wait and just like that we have
a a full-on random shift from the giffy
api would end and type safety because of
restful react I think this is absolutely
incredible and and here's the thing I
could I could swap that out for an array
of gifts for whatever and it just works
that is incredible so thank you it's
like one person better so let's wrap
this up I think that's absolutely
incredible and that's a powerful use
case that's enabled in react via
typescript and cogeneration and so we
have some of the benefits from graph QL
in react let's switch to the takeaways
I'd say number one constraints are your
friend we started the talk this way and
I will finish the talk this way if you
have a constraint you can get bitter you
can say stuff even whatever but I would
recommend use it to your advantage build
something fix the problem you I believe
you can
as an engineer types are your friend
Auto completion syntax
it's your friend nothing is really that
impossible except maybe you know some
stuff whatever but supposed to be
inspirational go with it and lastly I'd
encourage you to get creative and with
that I just would say thank you very
much for having me
Matt in react de Berlin but hang on a
second
there just one more thing I want to I
want to mention so we're almost at the
end of the day and the slides not up
okay whatever
we're almost there almost at the end of
the day and I have noticed you know the
the volunteers have been doing some
amazing stuff they've been serving you
may you may not even even notice them
but be the people behind the scenes to
make this conference work and I want to
take just a moment and point out one of
them specifically Conchita right here
will you stand up do you deserve if you
don't wanna set foot seated right here
um I have gotten to know the volunteers
and I'd encourage you like the person
who hands you your badge or something
get to know them they're incredible
people and they make all of this happen
so anyway thank you very much
you